imaginemos que todos nós nesta sala
fazemos parte de um comitê técnico
responsável por aprovar ou reprovar
substâncias químicas que pleiteiam ser
medicamentos facilmente
creio que os que conseguimos um consenso
entre dois requisitos básicos para uma
molécula ser um medicamento requisito um
que essa substância produza efeito que
seja eficaz requisito 2 que essa
substância não faça mal ou não seja
tóxica ou se apresentar efeitos adversos
que esses sejam suaves
creio que esse é um consenso fácil entre
nós aqui 300 pessoas
correto imaginamos então temos essas
duas moléculas que são candidatas a
medicamentos molécula 1 e molécula 2
temos relatórios técnicos à nossa
disposição para decidir se aprovamos ou
não essas moléculas e ambos os
relatórios dizem que ambas as moléculas
são efetivas produzem efeitos
farmacológicos que são benéficos para o
paciente requisito um rock em requisito
2 segurança
a molécula um é muito segura
você pode tomar doses superelevadas
desse medicamento que não tem nenhum
efeito adverso grave e nenhum risco de
morte
ótimo molécula dois não tão boa assim a
segurança é reduzida e se o paciente
tomar dez comprimidos ao invés de uma
por ter efeitos graves tópicos inclusive
chegar a óbito facilmente creio que esse
nosso comitê aqui nesse dia que a
molécula o um pode ser aprovada e
molécula 2 pode ser aprovada talvez com
algumas instituições como venda
controlada ou pesquisam sobre prescrição
médica mas na segunda parte do relatório
vem uma outra informação quem são essas
moléculas a molécula ou thc substância
química chamada canabinóide porque se
trata da planta cannabis
ativa complemente maconha ea mulher para
dois o paracetamol analgésico muito
utilizado no mundo todo com certeza
muitos de nós aqui tem casa compra de
forma livre sem receita médica
imagino que neste momento esse nosso
consenso antes entre 300 pessoas já não
vai mais um consenso roupa temos thc a
substância da maconha maconha a droga é
proibido é proibida
nós talvez alguns de nós iremos esquecer
os atuais técnicos e se apoiar nesse
estigma que nós temos com maconha não
apenas o nosso comitê tem esse problema
vários comitês e agências reguladoras ao
redor do mundo sofre influências não
científicas como deveria se pautar
apenas por dados científicos
vejam essas informações mortes anuais
nos estados unidos por algumas
substâncias álcool tabaco medicamentos
legais
o pop press etanol a morfina até mesmo a
cafeína que eu sou dependente mata
milhares de pessoas a cada ano ea
cannabis não mata ninguém
a cannabis até hoje não tem nenhum
relato na história da humanidade que foi
capaz de levar alguém a óbito
nem a cannabis e seus derivados mas é
ela que é proibida mesmo como droga de
recreação como o álcool eo tabaco ela
não é aceita por que isso acontece
se você pensa que fique news é algo
recente algo novo das mídias sociais
outras campanhas políticas pensou errado
talvez a maconha foi a substância que
mais sofreu foi pneus no século passado
uma campanha toda orquestrada contra
essa planta filmes documentários
propagandas entrevistas que imprensa
escrita todas falando mal da maconha
tentando nos convencer que ela é da
nossa tóxica e com alto poder viciante
sem nenhum fundamento científico
o problema é que quando se proíbe essa
planta não apenas o uso medicinal o uso
recreacional se proíbe se proíbe também
a pesquisa ea investigação e nós estamos
com
wako de 50 60 anos que perdemos na
história porque essa planta foi ou está
proibida
nós não sabemos quais é os reais
potenciais esse medicamento dessa planta
ainda estamos apenas começando essas
informações
no entanto nem tudo foi perdido ante 50
ou 60 anos eu destaco aqui dois grandes
cientistas que inclusive de maria de
ativistas científicos professor rafael
meshulam em israel e consolidar o
curling em são paulo aqui no brasil
apesar de todas as proibições esses
pesquisadores ainda ativos utilizam
muitas pesquisas algumas até
clandestinas
alguns de blanco suas ditaduras em suas
épocas de bandas leis estúpidas que
ainda seguem algumas delas para
demonstrar que a cannabis ou seja a
maconha é medicinal professor me shulan
sintetizou pela primeira vez o thc o
tetrahidrocanabinol e vários outros
canais menores da planta e três menores
também endógenos professor carlini aqui
no brasil nos anos 70 e 80
demonstrou que o cbd o canabidiol um
outro canabinóide da planta tem
atividades anti epilépticos a mais ou
menos 40 anos aqui no brasil e ainda
hoje muitas mães com filhos epilépticos
não tem apoio do estado não tem apoio da
medicina para conseguir cannabis para
reduzir as compulsões dos seus pequenos
essas mães e outros pacientes se sujem
sujeito ao tráfico de drogas a plantar
em casa
se o sujeito a se tornar criminosos para
conseguir ajudar os seus filhos os seus
inscritos num no entanto hoje em dia
graças a esses estudos muitas famílias
muitas mães muitos pacientes estão não
colocar pra conseguir fazer algo
diferente essas pessoas estão se expondo
estão ser reivindicado e estão inclusive
ensinando a médicos e pesquisadores os
efeitos da planta exatamente pacientes
estão ensinando médicos e pesquisadores
sobre os efeitos da planta
não é incomum médico dizer que receber
um paciente em seu consultório com uma
pilha de artigos científicos e falou
doutor leia se atualiza o que esses
artigos científicos mostram como afinal
a cannabis tem tantos poderes medicinais
a resposta quase tudo isso é o sistema
endocanabinóide sistema endocanabinóide
é um complexo de neurônios e enzimas que
produzem canabinóides todos nós aqui
nessa sala temos essas células que
produzem canabinóides que vamos indoor
nos na prática ou de fato todos nós
produzimos pequenas quantidades de
maconha todos os dias e são essas
substâncias que distribuem se distribuem
e atuam em todas essas áreas azuis em
verde dessa imagem ou seja em muitos
locais principalmente locais do sistema
nervoso central
hoje sabemos que essas substâncias vêm
do canabinóides ou seja os canabinóides
que nós produzimos são responsáveis uma
série de funções fisiológicas regulação
por exemplo do sono da fome do humor da
dor inflamação entre outros
então é óbvio se por algum motivo nós
produzimos menos canabinóides nós
podemos ter problemas com sono depressão
ansiedade entre outros
essas substâncias são muito importantes
para fazer uma grande ou menos trazia em
nosso organismo algo mais recente também
descoberto que todos nós à medida que
envelhecemos começamos a produzir menos
canabinóides ou seja idosos produzem
menos canabinóides que nós com 20 ou 30
anos
qual a relação disso se sabe exatamente
hoje que os caminhões produzidos em dose
na mente são responsáveis por por
proteger nosso cérebro e no sistema
nervoso central de várias patologias
então à medida que envelhecemos perdemos
canabinóides e nos conectamos mais
suscetíveis a várias doenças como
parkinson alzheimer e avc
e aí entra a nossa pequena contribuição
como laboratório
há dois anos eu fundei juntamente com
outros colegas na unila
o laboratório de neurofisiologia clínica
e nós temos como foco investigar os
efeitos da cannabis em pacientes com
parkinson e alzheimer
basicamente as patologias muito
recorrentes em pacientes já com uma
idade mais avançada
o parkinson por exemplo uma patologia
muito limitante do sistema do sistema
locomotor pessoas têm muitos tremores as
pessoas em dificuldades em sua locomoção
matilda imensa de iniciar e finalizar
movimentos nessa informação essa imagem
temos uma paciente com parkinson há dez
anos em duas situações
no gráfico superior temos ela antes de
receber cannabis no gráfico superior
terão inferior cinco semanas após
receber canaviais
o que avaliamos aqui é a capacidade dela
isso poder suspender a perna esquerda
esse movimento aqui pode-se observar que
antes de cannabis ela não consegue
retirar o pé do chão um momento mais
crítico dos seus sintomas chamado
período off a pé porque o ângulo de se
essas informações é praticamente zero no
amplitude do movimento no entanto após
cinco semanas uma dose muito baixo de
thc essa paciente consegue mesmo com
muitas limitações suspender essa perna
15 vezes
ou seja uma simulação do início e
manutenção de uma caminhada um paciente
que não consegue sequer se mexer está
tudo muito travado naquele momento é uma
grande recompensa também temos outros
resultados com alzheimer
aqui o trago um dado de um paciente com
alzheimer 75 anos com diagnóstico de
alzheimer já há três anos esse paciente
não podia mais sair de casa sozinho
muitas vezes que se o caminho de volta
às vezes não reconhecia amigos e
vizinhos e que se há torneiras abertas
ou às vezes o fogão aceso e após algumas
semanas de tratamento vejo ele teve uma
notável notável incremento no seu teste
de memória um protocolo padrão da
demência e esse efeito se mantém por
mais um ano
nenhum fármaco hoje no mercado consegue
fazer isso o efeito por mais um ano e
medicamento e com pacientes com
alzheimer
além disso como destaque esse paciente
que vive o município quatro horas aqui
de foz do iguaçu chamado planalto no
ponto seis meses pegou o ônibus sozinho
em sua cidade e ver até que na unila
para fazer a avaliação
hoje não tem mais esquecimento do dia a
dia e hoje está muito mais disposto e
bem-humorado segunda família segunda
esposa
outro destaque é isso são as doses que
utilizamos
vejam é de forma geral uma pessoa
necessita 30 miligramas de thc para ter
efeitos psicoativos ou inebriantes 30
miligramas como fumar um cigarro de
maconha
trabalhamos com doses em torno de uma
mesma gama ou até menos disso em torno
de 500 microgramas
ou seja damos aos nossos pacientes doses
60 vezes menores do que um cigarro de
maconha
por isso nosso paciente jamais ficou
chapados jamais couro vermelho
jamais com fome exacerbada
nossa teoria em nossos estudos estão
comprovando e com ele indo ao encontro
de outros estudos que mostram que uma
reposição de cannabis a doses baixas em
idosos podem prevenir e ajudar a tratar
doenças do sistema nervoso central
no entanto infelizmente é muito difícil
fazer esse tipo de pesquisa no brasil
ainda é muito difícil passar a ter
acesso a esse medicamento no brasil é
permitido fazer pesquisa prescrição
médica importar medicamento mas não é
permitido cultivar a planta seja tudo
inviável um paciente hoje necessita
desembolsar em torno de 5 mil reais por
mês pra conseguir o medicamento desse
que é importado
para o cientista também fica muito
difícil você trabalhar com doações vão
gastar o pouco dinheiro que temos em
pesquisa para comprar esses fármacos
creio que já está na hora do brasil
repensar essa legislação não é possível
que famílias mães de pessoas submeteu ao
crime
vai ter uma planta que não mata ninguém
para conter suas dores e seus problemas
não é possível não é possível que o
brasil esteja nesse atraso que já é
tempo de optarmos pela ciência e pela
verdade já é tempo de todos nós deixamos
para trás estigmas e preconceitos
ignorance is so essa planta porque mais
cedo ou mais tarde essas coisas estão
mudando e o brasil está perdendo seu
tempo porque hoje como a medicina fala
reposição hormonal para algumas mulheres
que atingem certa idade tenho certeza
que logo vai se falar em reposição
canábica quando pessoas atinjam 60 ou 70
anos
a recomendação médica vai ser pequenas
doses de cannabis todo dia porque quando
chegarmos aos 60 ou 70 muitos de nós tem
o netos
outros não alguns vamos passar o dia
todo no domingo na peça outros não mas
todos vamos querer ter saúde e para ter
saúde uma das nações vai ser cannabis em
pequenas doses todo dia porque a ciência
e os cientistas estão demonstrando cada
vez com mais evidência e hoje estamos
vendo que de fato maconha também é coisa
de velho obrigado